well first off
hope you guys are having a good
halloween if you're living in a
part of the world that celebrates
halloween um we have many subscribers
who actually don't
celebrate halloween um so happy saturday
saturday to you
uh this morning we actually lost a
legendary actor
um he passed away at 90 years old sean
connery and
um according to reports was he passed
away in the bahamas
and he was able to die peacefully and
asleep he was
suffering from certain illnesses that i
don't think were completely disclosed
at least at the time of not yet
recording this like
little video we want to do but sean
connery's passing
actually hit me a little bit harder than
i realized and then as i was reflecting
on this
it was really hitting me that he was his
there were movies of his that were such
a big part of
my childhood in particular as i'm sure
many of you guys right
um and i i kind of wanted to just talk a
little bit about him like
remember sean connery's legacy a bit
because
like you know growing up with my family
and both my mom and dad
um especially with my dad the one thing
that
i could always have a solid rapport with
them on
was movies and you know there were
several
sean connery movies that i know
were either on the background all the
time
or that sean connery was just
constantly being quoted for like so my
dad
funny enough like his last live action
movie
um that sean connery ever did was league
of extraordinary gentlemen i
remember he did some like voiceover work
afterwards but for league of
extraordinary gentlemen
my dad constantly i don't even know if
this is the right quote
but i remember in the trailer and it was
a movie we did oh not i personally had
you know i enjoyed it i thought it was
fun um
what he would always just go i'm waiting
to be impressed
this is something my dad would always
say i'm waiting to be impressed and i
i think that's the line that uh alan
quartermaine does say uh
it's a lot of the trailers it's it's
definitely the traffic i know the scene
um and then you know of course like i
think most people will probably
immediately associate his work of 007
james bond
and uh while that's such an influential
and important role like if it wasn't for
him we wouldn't have the longest running
franchise in movie history and he's
always the standard that people are
constantly you know
uh every bond has to be compared to
right
yeah well from what i understand where
he was when he passed was where they
shot much of i think thunderball or
something like that so like he even
interesting yeah it was in a place that
he would have spent a lot of time making
one of those bond movies so maybe
you know during that shoot he just fell
in love with the area or something
because
yeah i mean those films always have a
beautiful locale that's crazy
um and then some other movies that uh i
really grew up on like
bond wasn't really one of them doctor no
we watched a lot my dad had a laserdisc
of doctor now
so we watched a lot of doctor know um
and then later on in my life i would
eventually watch some of the other ones
he did but the ones that really hit me
the most were the ones that i
actually shared with my parents and
untouchables was one of them
his role was jim malone and okay
i'm not gonna quote it in some of the
lines that he says in the movie
but my dad my dad was the italian one so
there were certain lines that if you
guys have seen the untouchables
that you know he he says to a certain
italian character that my dad just loved
to quote
um i constantly in certain edits i'll
throw in
uh this moment of sean connery from
dragon heart just saying
i yeah i am the last one
yeah and uh so dragon heart was a movie
i really watched
a ton and uh my mom also
like she would have the hunt for red
october on playing console and that's
still a movie that i think is like
always on basic cable
and i just watched it again like a month
ago
i remember you telling me that yeah yeah
and then actually funny enough likewise
dragon heart and hunt for red october
were two that i grew up on
watched again recently and grew new
appreciations for as well as indiana
jones in the last crusade because that
was
one for me that i i know as growing up i
would have phases where i would play
certain tapes over and over again and
that one definitely
was was one because like he's he's like
america's grandpa in that movie
yeah he's incredible in that film she's
amazing yeah yeah he's amazing
he has one of the most iconic voices of
any uh any uh actor
have ever existed too you know like sean
connery impression is kind of
up there with like the people who do
like christopher walken and all that
i've come from spain i mean highlander
my my mom was obsessed with the
highlander series too so i watched a lot
of
specifically highlander one and two and
i think those are the only
two he if i'm not mistaken i think
there's he played ramirez in that and uh
uh yeah highlander was one i love
watching him in the rock
which is you know tattered as michael
bay's one good movie
the criterion collection like this is
all a good movie and uh the rock i'm
watching my dad i think two or three
dad and my brother two or three times in
uh in the theater
and i don't keep bringing up my family
but that that's just to show you like
wow
there really was a childhood association
that i had
with his films another one was uh
where he played king arthur in first
night um my mom would
let this movie play a lot which i
shouldn't have watched when i was
younger but we watched it a lot
it was a rising sun with him and wesley
snipes and
he's wonderful in the movie and i think
the thing with
sean connery i remember i wish i pulled
up the quote before recording this
obviously
was he said some thing
about how when it comes to his
profession as an actor
he knows that he just has a job to do
and then when he shows up on set
he just gives it i'm like paraphrasing
it but there's there's this quote that
always stuck to me about his work ethic
and i think it really does it really
does show in any movie that he ever did
was that even if the movie wasn't that
great he always gave it a hundred
percent i can't think of a time where i
saw something where he was phoning it in
yeah he took it with the utmost like as
serious as he could
and he committed full-heartedly to every
performance that he ever
gave he just always gave it his best
yeah and uh that's something about
why i think his legacy is just so
long-lasting and why he was able to do
movies for so many decades and i know
people wanted him to come out of
retirement for so long
but there's something kind of
bittersweet about his passing
because of the fact that he did retire
you know he did get a uh spent a lot of
his his last years not just
working he he got to enjoy a lot of his
life from my understanding at least
you know that's that's what's been
reported that's what's been talked about
when as much as people have tried
pulling him out of retirement he
wouldn't
you know well the funny thing to me is
like the things he did do after retiring
from on-screen work and as memeable as
something like sir billy is
like i appreciate it i heard a little
interviewer of bloib about that that
said he just wanted to do that because
it was like a scottish animation company
that was trying to get off the ground
and so it was
even though that movie isn't well
renowned it was like oh yeah you know
in the later years you know he probably
would have just done little things for
passion's sake or for the sake of yet
helping out people around and you look
at the
scope of his career and it's like he'll
have some of these iconic roles that are
so widespread and well-known like a
james bond
and then you'll see him in certain
things like the league of extraordinary
gentlemen or whatever that have their
meme
qualities but then also too like one of
my favorite
sean connery joints that kind of blew my
mind back when i first saw it at like a
revival house cinema was
zardoz which is like this completely
surreal he's running around like a thong
half the time with like a gun belt on
and they're floating heads and like
that was another one my dad looked
that's a photo
it was a strange movie put on an album
and put on zardoz and have yourself a
mood night but yeah it seemed like over
the breadth of his career he did a
little bit of everything and no matter
what kind of
viewer you are there's probably
something in him
in his catalog that can you know reach
to you and i also appreciate that as
much as it is kind of a meme that he's
always
sean connery for the most part in voice
even when he's like a russian submarine
commander or a man from spain
like there's something about him and his
personality and his charisma on screen
that transcends those things and just
kind of feels right
even if you know there are things you
can picket them for so yeah like he is a
a unique like he's always been there in
my life and it's kind of surreal
he's one of those people i never
imagined would die i mean he's played a
lot of tough guys and such but even
like and i think his work in indiana
jones is one of his most iconic roles
and
you know it's a character who gets
tougher but when he starts off he's kind
of killed early
yeah you know he's he's scared easily
and uh he feels really much like a
father yeah movie so
i i feel like he did have range that
might have been a bit underappreciated
definitely because he is usually
associated as just a tough guy tough
debonair
yeah um but yeah guys i mean just
for someone of his legacy put down in
the comments you know
what what are movies that really stood
out to you
uh movies of his that you watched
growing up a lot entrapment was one
constantly watching it on an airplane i
think that was one of the like earliest
dvds we ever owned it was entrapment
you know and i remember that movie at
the time was like the height of like ooh
hot espionage action
may he rest in peace man rest in peace
sean connery
uh prayers to his loved ones and yeah
celebrate his legacy watch a sean
connery movie sometime
he really was a legend in this field